[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and welcome
to episode number 126
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I'm Mark Mandel and I'm here
with my colleague, as always,
Melanie Warrick.
How are you doing
today, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm doing good.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm doing very
well, very chipper today.
MELANIE WARRICK: You
are very chipper.
MARK MANDEL: I am
very chipper today.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So this week, Mark,
we're going to be
talking with Holden,
who's one of our colleagues,
about Beam and Spark.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
two great open source
projects for processing
big data at scale.
MELANIE WARRICK: Definitely.
Before that, as always, we
talk about our cool things
of the week and
we do our question
of the week at the end.
And this week's question
of the week is--
I have a continuous
integration build
process set up with
Container Builder,
but it's all sequential.
I want to speed things up
by processing parts of it
in parallel.
How do I do that?
But first, as always,
cool things of the week.
Twitter is moving parts
of its process to GCP.
And we have a link
to the blog post that
talks about that as well as
some other additional kind
of funny little bits.
Apparently, it's moving
its cold data storage
and flexible compute
Hadoop clusters
to Google Cloud Platform, which
is over 300 petabytes of data.
And fun fact--
Greg Wilson, our
fearless leader,
had pointed out that
back in the day,
for any of you out there
who watch "Star Trek Next
Generation"--
[SPACE WARP SOUND]
MARK MANDEL: I do.
MELANIE WARRICK:
--may have noticed
that Data, the actual
robot, admitted to his brain
having about 100
petabytes of data.
MARK MANDEL: So Twitter
has more data than Data.
[DIGITAL SOUND]
MELANIE WARRICK: Basically.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's cool.
Maybe we will finally
see Data come to life.
Another cool thing of the week--
Kaggle is running a contest in
collaboration with CERN, CERN
being a research
organization that
operates the largest
particle physics
laboratory in the world.
And so this competition,
in particular,
is taking a lot of their
data that they've collected
and getting outside
support in terms of seeing,
can machine learning assist
in high energy physics
of discovering and
characterizing new particles?
What's cool about
the competition,
outside of the fact that
there's $25,000 prize money--
MARK MANDEL: Naturally.
MELANIE WARRICK: that's
associated to it--
always good--
is that it's coming
in two parts.
And so the first part
of the competition
is going to be May to July.
And they'll be focusing
on the high score.
And it's more
about the accuracy,
and this aligns
with the conference
IEEE WCCI competition that
that's being presented in July.
And then there's
a throughput phase
that's really more focused
on the speed in terms
of processing.
And so this is aligned
to a phase that's
between July to October
and will wrap up
at Neural Information Processing
Systems Conference in December.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So we've got
a bunch of announcements
around, strangely enough,
containers and Kubernetes.
I think one of the ones
I'm really excited about
is a product called gVisor which
we open sourced back in May 2.
This is really interesting.
This is a new kind of sandbox
that provides secure isolation
for containers while still
being more lightweight
than a virtual machine.
So it integrates with
Docker and Kubernetes,
but really, I think what's
kind of exciting about this
is it really imposes a very
strong, secure isolation
layer for when you want to run
code that you don't necessarily
trust.
Maybe it comes from outside
or you're opening things up,
or maybe you just want the
extra layer of security.
I think it's really, really
cool in that it really
allows you to be
able to run things
in a very secure environment.
Now, there is a trade-off.
At its core there is
a userspace kernel
that basically emulates
the Linux kernel, which
does mean that the
flexibility that you get
comes at the price of higher
per-system call overhead.
And there are some
details in the blog post.
But this is really exciting.
Look for integrations
with Docker.
There's a sample in the blog
post about how you can run it
with Docker right now,
some experimental support
potentially within
Kubernetes as well.
Its going to come down the line.
So there's some really
interesting opportunities
here for being able
to build some really
interesting platforms
for customers
on top of this technology.
I'm really excited about it.
MELANIE WARRICK: And then one
of our colleagues, Ian Lewis,
has a demo.
There's a video, actually,
at the end of the blog post
that we'll include
in the show notes.
And you should check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Speaking of
Kubernetes, of course,
we announced the Stackdriver
Kubernetes' monitoring system.
Basically, this is really cool.
I really like this too.
It's essentially a single
pane of monitoring glass
for your Kubernetes
cluster whether or not
they run like us on
GKE, or whether they
run on-prem or other places.
This is great too.
It also hooks into Prometheus,
which is pretty much
the standard or the
default open source
monitoring system as well.
So you've got a lot
of options there.
I really like this.
Right now, it will be available
in production clusters as soon
as Kubernetes hits 1.10
on Kubernetes Engine.
But you can try it
right now if you
want to run an alpha cluster
on us and take it for a spin.
That should be available to you
so you can see what it's like.
And we definitely want
to hear your feedback,
so in the blog post that we'll
link to there is a Google Group
where you can send all sorts
of questions and feedback
to us as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
One last thing we're going
to mention for this week
is that Google
Research is actually
participating and
MLPerf.org, which
is this effort to
basically set benchmarks
to measure systems
performance for both training
and inference in machine
learning performance.
So this is a
collaborative effort
that's going on across a number
of different corporations
as well as education
institutions and research
organizations like
the University
of California at Berkeley,
Stanford, Harvard, Google,
Intel, Baidu, AMD.
So basically, they're
working together
to try to come up with common
standard benchmarks, which
I think is really wonderful.
And we will include the
link in the show notes,
and you can check it out.
All right, Mark, we had a lot
of cool things of the week
especially because
KubeCon was last week.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, it was.
MELANIE WARRICK: Now
I think it's time
for us to go talk with Holden.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do it.
Today, I am particularly excited
to have the always effervescent
Holden Karau with us today.
Holden, how are you doing today?
HOLDEN KARAU: I'm good.
I've got coffee, which I've
been told not to drink.
So I'm really looking
forward to when this is over
and I can drink my coffee.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, thanks for
joining us today to chat
all about Beam and Spark.
Before we do that,
though, do you
want to tell us a little
bit about who you are
and what you do here at Google,
and all that sort of stuff?
HOLDEN KARAU: Sure.
So I focus mostly on open
source big data tools, so things
like Beam, Spark, to a lesser
degree other things like Kafka,
which are not data
processing per se,
although moving more
in that direction.
And that's my main focus, is the
open source tools that we have.
And I mostly do sort of
external-facing work,
not a lot of internal stuff.
But I do occasionally have
delightful conversations
with people about ways
we can make our products,
which are built on top of
these open source things,
more awesome.
It's fun.
People pay me to
write open source code
and fly around the world,
so my life is pretty cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: And how did
you get involved with Spark
and Beam to begin with?
HOLDEN KARAU: So I got involved
with Spark from the last time
I was working at Google.
There was this thing
called FlumeJava,
which was kind of cool.
But I couldn't use it for
any of my personal projects.
And somehow back then, I
still had time in my life
for personal projects.
And I was like, I really want to
use this software but I can't.
So I looked around for an
open source reimplementation
of Google technology, which
is a pretty common approach
in the big data world,
and I found Spark.
And I was like, oh, cool.
This uses functional
programming.
This is awesome.
That's sort of how I
got started with Spark.
And that was a lot of fun.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Was that in Scala,
when you were working with it?
HOLDEN KARAU: I mean,
Spark started in Scala.
And it's still in Scala
now, but you can use it
in other languages as well.
But for me, Scala was
actually a pretty good fit.
I'd just come from
Foursquare where
everything was built in Scala.
And I really like
functional programming.
I think it's kind of a nice way
of thinking about the world.
And so I really
enjoyed a framework
that really put a functional
approach to dealing with data.
I felt it was a really cool fit.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Let's take a small step back.
For those people who
aren't as familiar
with, say, Spark or Beam,
what's the kind of problem
that those products
are trying to solve?
HOLDEN KARAU: Both
Spark and Beam,
and a lot of other
things in this space,
essentially solve
the problem of--
you have a lot of data and you
want to do something with it,
and it's too much data to fit on
a single computer or maybe even
a few single computers.
And it's about splitting the
problems up, distributing
both the data and
the computation,
and then collecting the
results back in a way
that you can use them.
So some of the classic
problems where people use this
are things like training
recommendation systems
where you have a
lot of information
from all of your
different users.
Other times it's things
like fraud detection
where we'll have a
lot of transactions
and we'll want to train models.
It's not just machine learning.
It's also often used for ETL.
We might have an old legacy
database which we also
want to expose in a nicer way.
And so you might have a batch
job which comes in and picks up
your data from your
legacy database
and makes it available to people
to do exploratory analytics on.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
where did Beam come from?
HOLDEN KARAU: Beam came
from a large number
of different Google projects.
It's sort of the grandchild,
in a way, of MillWheel
and other things like this.
So it's the grandchild of a
lot of Google big data tools.
It brings a lot of the
learnings that we've
had from working on MapReduce
and working on things
like MillWheel and
other analytics tools,
and brings them all
together into one place.
The idea is that Beam will
provide a portability layer
from Google Dataflow, which
exposes all of these cool tools
to people to use, to things
besides Google Dataflow.
Because as much as we love
people that use Google tools,
not everyone wants
to write their code
against just a Google backend.
They want to be able to
run it in multiple places.
Some people have
analytics jobs which
they need to do both on data
which is less secretive,
and then they have
similar jobs which
have to be run on
super-secret data which
they can't put in the cloud yet
for, maybe, regulatory reasons.
And so having a system which is
able to both run in the cloud
and run on-prem is
a really cool idea.
And it's one where
we have, perhaps,
not quite delivered what
we set out to do initially.
But I'm really excited
about the direction
we're taking with it this year.
I just yesterday
was at Flink Forward
where we were talking about
some of the work which we've
been doing around making
Beam on top of Flink, which
is an open source
Apache project, a better
experience for people.
MARK MANDEL: So
this sounds great.
But you work on
Spark and on Beam.
HOLDEN KARAU: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Are they
competing open source products?
Or what's the
relationship there?
HOLDEN KARAU: So
it's complicated.
I want to be clear--
there's also Apache Flink
and other open source
runners which do similar
data processing tools.
And we all take slightly
different approaches
to solving the same problem.
And at the end of
the day, what happens
is we tend to go and steal the
best ideas from each other.
Because it's open source
and we can do that.
Everyone wins this way, right?
And we also, by competing with
each other to some degree,
push the state of
the market forward.
And so in some places, Beam
and Spark are competitors.
In other places,
you could actually
use Beam on top of Spark.
And so they can
be complementary.
And it's really confusing if
you're not from an open source
background to think of
this mixture of competing
and cooperating
at the same time.
But I think it's a
really good model.
MARK MANDEL: Are
there particular cases
where you would use, say, one
or the other, or together?
HOLDEN KARAU: The cases where
you would use Beam is probably
more around streaming.
Historically, Spark
Streaming has had,
maybe, not as great
support as in Beam.
Although Spark Streaming is,
of course, also improving.
One of the things
which continues
to happen in these places
is we'll do something cool,
someone else will
do something cool.
Sometimes it will actually
be the same developer
in two different projects.
Like there's pieces
of code that I've
written which are
not the same code,
but accomplish the same
task in both Spark and Beam.
Anyways, back to Beam.
You're more likely
to use it if you're
interested in portability
between Google
Cloud and an on-prem solution,
or other things like that.
Spark, though, for
example, has, really,
much more options in
terms of machine learning.
From a programmatic
standpoint, the Beam SDK
is very much focused around
whole program optimization.
And it's really
cool, and you can
do a bunch of interesting
things as a result.
But because of the way how
it was initially built,
it's kind of difficult to
do iterative algorithms
like gradient descent,
which are really
common in machine learning.
And so Spark has a
more full-featured set
of machine learning tools that
are available for it right now.
Although of course,
Beam is looking
at what it can do to improve
its machine learning options.
And none of these things
really ever remain static.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
you've talked about how
they're both open source.
We also have them at GCP.
And so how does that work?
They're managed versions
of these products?
HOLDEN KARAU: Indeed.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
if so, what are they?
HOLDEN KARAU: Glorious employer
provides excellent managed
solutions.
MELANIE WARRICK: I wasn't
teeing that one up at all
for that one.
HOLDEN KARAU: There's Dataflow
where you can run Beam.
Beam on top of Dataflow is
a really good experience.
Spark actually has two
different managed backends
which you could use at
Google, and different levels
of support associated with
those different backends,
both in terms of just
functionality and actual
support.
So Dataproc is probably
what most people
think of as the managed
solution for Spark at Google.
I'm really excited about
where we're going with that.
There's a lot of exciting
improvements we can make there.
The other one, which is new--
in Spark 2.3 we added
support for Kubernetes.
And this is really
exciting because it now
means that Spark can run
on top of things like GKE.
And actually, it's a little
clunky to use right now,
but with Spark on
top of Kubernetes
you really need a
separate distributed file
system available.
Because it doesn't
tend to ship with one,
whereas Spark on
Dataproc traditionally
ships with an HDFS
YARN provider.
So running Spark on
Kubernetes in the cloud
is a much better
experience because you
tend to have an object store,
like GCS, available to use.
So it's pretty cool.
Spark on GKE is like
a managed service,
but if you run
into difficulties--
I mean, it's like a managed
service on the Kubernetes side.
And if you run into
Spark-specific difficulties,
you're probably not going
to get as much support
as you would if you
were in Dataproc.
But it's a really fun way to
try out cutting-edge stuff.
And I actually have a blog
post on the GCP big data
blog about how you can try
out different new versions
of Spark.
And actually-- not that I'm
just trying to get people to do
my work for me--
MELANIE WARRICK: But you are.
MARK MANDEL: It's called
delegation, I believe.
HOLDEN KARAU: Well, no, no.
It's delegation when
we're at the same company.
And it's valued
partnership building.
MELANIE WARRICK: There you go.
HOLDEN KARAU: That's going in
my personal accomplishments
if anyone actually
picks up these tasks.
Please do.
So one of the things
which I would really
like the community's help
with-- and especially if you
are a Spark user--
if you're not,
don't feel obligated
to do this at all.
But come release time,
we have this process
where we make candidates
for release, right?
And it's like, we think this
is a pretty good release.
But we're limited
by the workloads
that we know about, right?
And this is open source
"we," not the Google "we."
And so the people
involved with the Spark
project, the core developers,
it's a large set of people
but it's not completely
representative of actual users.
And if you wanted to,
and you were using GCP,
you could try out your workloads
on top of Spark with GKE
with one of these
release candidates
with the instructions
in that blog post.
And if it doesn't
work, you can let
us know so we don't
release broken software
and have to patch
it later, right?
You can help us catch
our bugs earlier.
And we can make better
software together.
MARK MANDEL: So if
you already have,
maybe, a production
workload set up on, say,
GKE or something like that,
you could spin it up and just
take it for a test run
and see what happens.
HOLDEN KARAU: Totally.
But definitely
take it for a test
run in an account
with lower permissions
so that you don't
overwrite your data,
just in case we screwed
up really badly.
MARK MANDEL: Or make
a copy or something.
HOLDEN KARAU: Yeah, sure.
Copies are cheap, right?
I don't actually know how
much we charge for anything.
MARK MANDEL: Cloud
privilege, I understand that.
MELANIE WARRICK: What's changed
to make both Beam and Spark
put so much focus on
non-JVM languages?
HOLDEN KARAU: So I
think the biggest
change is that deep learning
is very cool right now.
And people are trying to raise
money in Silicon Valley--
I mean, we're not.
We are a publicly
traded company.
But a lot of the open source
companies are like, ooh,
I need to add some AI to my--
MELANIE WARRICK: Spread some
AI on that and it looks good.
HOLDEN KARAU: Yeah,
it looks a lot better.
We're not just a
big data company,
we're a big data machine
learning company.
But you know, big
data machine learning
isn't as cool as big
data deep learning.
There are some JVM
tools for deep learning.
But there's not quite the
same full range of options
as there are in Python
or other languages.
And a lot of people
really want to be
able to just copy and paste
the Python code and have it run
rather than translate
it into Java,
because it's a lot
less work for raising
your next round of funding.
And so really, it comes
down to that people in Java
now are actually wanting
to use Python code.
And this is really
exciting as someone
whose job it is to make
Python and Java work together.
That's my role to
a large degree.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Those communities
don't always get along, too.
HOLDEN KARAU: No,
historically they
have very nice things
to say about each other.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, they do.
They very much respect,
wholeheartedly,
each other's different
point of views on coding.
But anyway, yes,
you were saying?
HOLDEN KARAU: Yeah,
it's super awkward
when you're in between
those two communities.
And you're just like, hm,
maybe let's stop making
fun of classes.
Or like, I know the drill is the
thing, but it's not that bad.
Anyways, whatever.
MELANIE WARRICK: I actually
like both languages
for different reasons and
don't like both languages
for different reasons.
But yes, I can see where
the disconnect comes from.
HOLDEN KARAU: But getting
back to the main point
of your question,
people are now trying
to use Python code from Java.
And it's really exciting because
the Python people have always
been trying to use some
of the big data Java code.
And now that both sides
are working together
rather than just random
people like me hanging out
in the middle, there's
a lot more interest.
And so you see projects
like Apache Arrow which
are really exciting and
provide a common data
format between the
different languages
so they can inter-operate
a lot better.
And so this is, I
think, really exciting.
MARK MANDEL: Is it just Python?
HOLDEN KARAU: No.
Arrow is not just Python.
It's Python, R, Java--
I think JavaScript, but
don't hold me to that one--
and Go.
People were talking about
it on the mailing list.
And I'm sure there's more that
I'm just not keeping up with.
I mostly care about
the Python community,
but other things are good too.
MARK MANDEL: And
does that mean, then,
you can use those languages
on Spark or Beam as well?
Or is that just Python
and Java derivatives?
HOLDEN KARAU:
Yeah, so it doesn't
mean that we can necessarily
use those languages together.
In Spark, we can use both
Python and R. In Beam,
there's actually
interesting work
being done to add support for
Go, which is actually something
that I demoed yesterday
at Flink Forward.
Word count is the best demo
ever at a big data conference.
We counted a lot of words--
genuine big data.
So Beam doesn't actually
depend on Arrow.
Because Beam has this
sort of Google lineage,
it actually uses FlatBuffers
and other things like this which
are very similar to Arrow
but are slightly different
in pretty uninteresting ways
unless you really like C++
code, which is fine too.
It's more or less
unrelated, but they're
following similar approaches.
And just because we
have a common format
to get the data
between each other,
there's this other
challenge where
we have to figure out a
way to take our functions
and serialize them and
send them across the wire,
and deal with that in a
nice way for execution
on another machine.
And so in Python, that's
a moderate amount of work.
And we use a weird custom
serializer to make it happen.
In Go, it's also a
non-trivial amount of work.
And so there's
other problems that
have to be solved to make
a language work here.
But having a common data format
is one of the prerequisites.
So it's exciting to
see that part get
unlocked for more languages.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
For someone who hasn't touched
Spark or Beam, what does
the development cycle look like?
How does that whole process go?
Like if I have some
data and I want
to process it to either
learn something about it
or change it, what
does that look like?
HOLDEN KARAU: So
they actually have
slightly different processes
as common first paths.
In Spark, it's really
common to get started
by opening up a
notebook and just
poking at your data for a
while to be like, I wonder--
maybe it does-- no,
that doesn't work.
OK, what about this?
It's a very iterative nature.
That tends to be more for
Python and Scala developers.
Java developers, you spin up
a new project, you make a JAR,
you submit it to the cluster,
you take a look at it.
And it's a little
more heavyweight
when you're working
in Java, and it's also
a little more heavyweight when
my cost to test something out
is compiling my project
and submitting the JAR.
Even though like it may take
similar amounts of time,
the mental overhead is
more than Shift+Enter.
And so for Java
developers, it tends
to be more like you'll
print out your schemas,
you'll look at it, you'll
make a quick test pipeline.
And then you'll sample the
data and run it through
to see what happens.
And with Python and Scala
developers in the Spark land,
you tend to use a notebook and
sort of poke at it that way.
MARK MANDEL: So more like
an online REPL type thing.
HOLDEN KARAU: Yeah.
And then the Beam
online REPL thing--
it's not so happy just yet.
It's more focused
around traditional jobs
where you submit a
package to the cluster.
MARK MANDEL: So
basically, I write
some code in some language,
I submit it to the cluster,
and it's the cluster's job that
splits that up and parallelizes
that work?
HOLDEN KARAU: Totally.
If you really want, you can do
things slightly differently.
One of the things
which I do because I
travel so much is I'll also--
if I'm working with
non-sensitive data,
I'll sample my data and save
it locally to my machine.
And then both Beam and
Spark have this concept
of a local mode runner
where you can just
run your stuff against a local
copy of your data to just check
and make sure that it works so
your development cycle isn't
super long.
You're not always having
to submit something
to the cluster.
You can just try
stuff out locally
before you run it on
your genuine "big data."
There's air quotes around
that, just to clarify.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
What type of machine
learning options are there?
HOLDEN KARAU: In Spark, there's
a lot of different machine
learning options.
From a design point of view,
writing iterative algorithms
in Spark is a lot easier than
in Beam.
So things like gradient
descent are just
a little easier to write in
Spark just because of the way
these two platforms
were developed.
And so Spark has kind of a
head start and a lead there.
And you can do linear
regression, just
classic, good old
fashioned stuff.
You can make your
decision trees,
you can make your
random forests,
all of the classical
both regression
and classification algorithms.
And then there's also this
collection of Spark packages
which essentially comes from--
I mean, there's just not enough
ML reviewers inside of Spark.
And when people show up with
new algorithms I'm just like,
I could read your paper.
Or I could take a bath.
And then--
MELANIE WARRICK: And read
it while you're in the bath.
HOLDEN KARAU: Yeah-- no.
That's where email gets done.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's important.
HOLDEN KARAU: Very important.
But no, it's just
the amount of work
to review an algorithm
for inclusion
is really, really high
because you want to make sure
it's correct.
And you also want to make
sure that it's maintained.
And nothing against
grad students.
I love grad students
and their code.
But pretty frequently,
a lot of people
will show up with an
algorithm that they've
implemented in Spark from
part of their grad project.
And it's just like,
we'd love to take this,
but we also know you're
going to graduate really soon
and who's going to maintain this
when you go work in industry
or go and become
a full professor?
Maybe you'll get your
new, tiny grad students
to look after this,
but I'm not sure.
If you want to go and try
that grad student code,
you can totally go to
Spark-packages.org and scroll
through the list of grad
student machine learning models
and pick your favorite one,
and just hope they keep it up
to date or your business process
changes before you need any bug
fixes.
Or you can become a
machine learning developer
yourself, which is great.
And if you make your business
process depend on it first,
well, there's not a
lot your boss can do.
MELANIE WARRICK: Whether you're
doing machine learning or not,
what does it look like to
contribute to Beam and Spark?
HOLDEN KARAU: Totally.
So they're both
open source projects
and they're both within
the Apache Foundation.
And this is cool
because it means
that there's some common
elements of culture
between the two.
Obviously, the people
are different--
or sorry, not obviously.
But the people are different
between the two to some degree.
And so there are different
cultural practices
that have developed.
But there is sort of
a common framework
for how you go about those.
In both cases, you
start by subscribing
to the developer mailing list.
And it tends to be like
dev-subscribe@beam.apache.org
or
dev-subscribe@spark.apache.org.
And then you can subscribe
to the mailing list
and you can start to see
what other developers are
working on.
And then you can also say, like,
hey, what's up, I'm new here.
Does anyone want to
give me some guidance?
If you do that on
the Spark project,
there's a really good
chance you'll get ignored.
If you do that in the Beam
project, it's more likely
people will be like,
yay, new friends!
And this is mostly just because
Beam is a younger open source
project than Spark.
And so it's easier to be like, I
don't have 200 other people I'm
already working with, here's
a new person, let's do this.
And in Spark, it's like
I have 200 open pull
requests that I need to review.
If you come with some code,
I'll help you, but not yet.
And so that can be
a little different.
In both cases, JIRA is
used to track the issues.
You can go into JIRA, you
can look at open issues.
You can look at things
which people have maybe
tagged as starter issues.
They're broken
down by components,
so I myself, personally,
mostly go and look
at either the Python or
ML issues in each project
and see if there's anything
that people are encountering
as either bugs or improvements
that I want to work on.
And those are things
that I pick up and do.
And then they're both on GitHub.
They both accept pull requests.
And you can sort
of go from there.
They each have their own
contributing guide as well,
on their websites,
that you can look at.
And they have style
guides as well.
Because when you have open
source projects like this,
you want a consistent
style even though we
don't work at the same
company and don't have
the same shared style guides.
So each project
has its own style.
Switching between
the two projects
is great because the
styles are different.
And that's just super easy
to keep straight in my head.
And I love my life.
MELANIE WARRICK:
What are you excited
about the work you're doing?
HOLDEN KARAU: Well, there's
different kinds of excitement,
right?
There's excitement
about code and there's
excitement about code
other people are writing.
And then there's
excitement about people
that I get to meet when I go
out into the open source world.
So the excitement about code
that I'm writing is mostly--
there's some stuff
around improving
the speed at which Python and
Java are able to work together.
And that is something
I'm personally
really passionate about.
And I'm excited to
make that more awesome.
And I actually have a
talk at Spark Summit
SF about how you can use that to
use TensorFlow inside of Spark.
And you can use similar
techniques inside of Beam,
but it's more complicated.
And so that talk will
probably be a quarter later
once they work out
some more bugs.
So like, one thing
then the other thing.
Code other people are writing
that I'm excited about--
there's a lot of really
interesting exciting things
in both projects which
are happening around
sort of improving
the SQL experience.
And I think this
is a thing which
is often overlooked, at least
among people like myself.
MARK MANDEL: Is this like
a BigQuery experience type
thing in Spark?
Is that kind of how that works?
HOLDEN KARAU: It's is
similar to BigQuery,
except it runs with the Spark
Engine so it's less managed.
And there's more of a
maintenance overhead.
But the idea is that you
can write SQL queries
against your
traditional big data.
The nice thing
about that is if you
work with someone from,
maybe, more of a data analyst
background who might be more
comfortable working with SQL,
they might produce some
really cool insights.
And then it becomes your
job to productionize them.
And then that can sometimes
mean rewriting SQL in the Java.
And that's no units of fun.
But instead, because it has
an integrated SQL engine,
you can just plop that SQL
statement in and then rewrite
the critical path or
the expensive parts
into your Java
code while keeping
most of the existing SQL code.
Or if the SQL code
runs fine, you
can just plop it into your
JAR and consume it downstream
in the rest of
your ETL pipeline.
Anyway, so there's improvements
happening in both Beam
and Spark around SQL, and
that's really exciting
to see that happening.
MELANIE WARRICK: Are there any
other improvements or future
features that you're
looking forward to?
HOLDEN KARAU: Yeah.
In both cases, they're
open source projects.
So there's features which
I think might happen.
But it's really
difficult to say for sure
what will happen because
it comes down to what
the community ends up wanting.
And even if, for example, I
were to show up with code,
there's no guarantee
that that's going
to be what the community wants.
I can commit my stuff in Spark--
if we don't have a consensus,
it's considered impolite
to make changes--
more than impolite.
But it's important that
we all work together.
And there are things
which are far enough
along that I'm pretty sure
they're going to happen.
Like, the SQL improvements
are going to happen.
And everything else
is a little more--
eh, who knows if it'll happen?
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
You mentioned that you've got
a lot of talks that you do.
Were there any
talks in particular
that you wanted to
talk about that you're
going to be doing soon?
HOLDEN KARAU: Yeah, I have some
ones that I'm excited about.
I'll be at PyCon
very soon as well.
I'll actually go from
PyCon to Scala Days,
which is very symbolic of
my life in a lot of ways.
Both of those
talks are exciting.
And I love both the Python and
Scala communities so I'm really
looking forward to that in May.
And I'll also be at Strata
London and then J on the Beach.
I've never been to J
on the Beach before,
but from what my
coworkers have told me,
it's a really
amazing conference.
So I'm looking forward
to that as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: What
does the "J" stand for?
HOLDEN KARAU: Java.
MELANIE WARRICK: Java?
OK.
HOLDEN KARAU: And Spark
Summit SF, of course, in June.
I'm really excited
about that talk.
I think it's going
to be really cool.
And I really hope my
demo doesn't crash.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
I don't know, J
on the Beach makes
me think sandals standing out
on the beach with a projector?
HOLDEN KARAU: I don't
think it's actually
physically on the beach.
Although I did go
to a conference--
MARK MANDEL: Now
I'm disappointed.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, me too.
HOLDEN KARAU: Well,
no, I could be wrong.
I went to a conference in
Amsterdam where I was like,
there's no way this is
actually on the water.
And then I was like, oh, this
is on a boat on the water.
OK, cool.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
HOLDEN KARAU: And so if it is,
I can get out my mermaid tail,
probably.
And that will be an
exciting opportunity
to give a mermaid presentation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SPLASHING]
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Sweet.
MARK MANDEL: All right.
Well, before we wrap
up today, is there
anything we haven't
mentioned or something
cool you want to talk about?
HOLDEN KARAU: One
of the other things
which I'm passionate about as
well is testing and validating
these big data pipelines.
I think it's really important.
It's often overlooked because
it's a little harder to do
than in our other projects.
And a lot of humans,
when encountered
with a problem slightly harder
which literally does not
catch on fire, just
kind of walk around it.
And while it doesn't
catch on fire,
it does catch on fire later.
In a little survey that I ran
with a few hundred respondents,
15% of people said that their
big data pipelines cause
serious production outages.
And that's a lot.
And I enjoy not having to
keep an up-to-date resume,
and I assume other
people do too.
I also don't want
the software projects
that I work on to be
responsible for my death.
So I think people
should definitely
test their Spark and Beam code.
In Spark, there is this
project called Spark Testing
Base, which I work on,
which makes it easier
to test your code.
And in Beam, it's
actually really
nice-- there's
built-in primitives
for doing high-quality testing.
There's things called P asserts
which make it really easy to do
pipeline assertions in Beam.
And I think they're really
cool and, perhaps, underused.
And so I would always
encourage people-- please test
and validate your pipelines.
If you don't know how, I
have talks on this subject.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
We'll chuck some
in the show notes.
Well, Holden, thank you so
much for joining us and hanging
out with us today.
It was an absolute pleasure.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
HOLDEN KARAU: Thank
you for having me.
And I can drink my
coffee now, right?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, you
can drink your coffee.
And yes, it was a lot of fun.
So we're glad you joined us.
HOLDEN KARAU: Yay, I didn't
even swear that much!
MELANIE WARRICK: Or at all.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you very much.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank
you again, Holden.
That was wonderful to talk
with you about Spark and Beam.
And I really have fun, actually,
hearing your perspective
on the world around
us, actually.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's always
great to chat with Holden.
Big fan, big fan.
MELANIE WARRICK:
All right, to Mark.
Question of the week?
MARK MANDEL:
Question of the week.
MELANIE WARRICK: So I have
a continuous integration
build process set up
with Container Builder.
But it's all sequential.
So to speed things up, how would
I basically process parts of it
in parallel?
MARK MANDEL: So I found
this out the other day
and I got really,
really excited about it.
I'll talk through,
basically, how
I've got things set up so that
it properly gives some context.
So I've got a continuous build
process running, strangely
enough, for [INAUDIBLE].
It has a bunch of build steps.
I run tests, and then
I build some images.
And then I put those images up
on Container Registry, pretty
standard continuous
integration type things.
But they're all
sequential, right?
So I have to wait for my
tests to finish before I start
building my container images.
So I have to run my tests
and then build my binaries,
then push my binaries
into the container image,
and build the image.
And it's all sequential.
Now in theory, I
could run my tests
at the same time I'm
building my binaries, right?
There's really no
reason why I have
to wait for one or the other.
If either of them fail,
then that's it, we're done.
And I didn't think you could
do this in Container Builder,
but you can.
There's basically a
configuration option
called waitFor.
We'll put a link
in the show notes
to the exact documentation.
But there's a configuration
option for each step
that you can put in waitFor.
You can put waitFor dash, which
just says start it right away,
I don't care.
I'm not going to wait
for anything else.
But you can also
give IDs to steps.
And then basically, you just
say, wait for this list of IDs.
So you can do both splittings
or you can split out.
So like first one starts,
and then three will go,
and then you can do
joining back again.
So you wait for all of
these steps to complete
and it comes back.
And so you can do parallel
processing and speed up your
build.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
Well, thanks for
that tip of the week.
So Mark, are you going anywhere
fun, fabulous, speaking
someplace soon?
MARK MANDEL: I don't
think I am at the moment.
I'm still doing stuff for Next,
still live streaming on Twitch.
MELANIE WARRICK: And this week
I/O is happening as we speak.
MARK MANDEL: Yes,
there's that too.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That is going on.
MARK MANDEL: You're not
going down to I/O are you?
MELANIE WARRICK:
I'm not going to I/O
because I will be in
San Diego, actually,
the day this is launched.
I will be at Internet2
Global Summit speaking on
a panel either before or
after this gets launched.
So yeah, that's this week.
MARK MANDEL: Cool, excellent.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, Mark.
It's been fun.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Thanks again for joining
me on this week's episode
of the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: And thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]